tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj e se ci sia venuto un po
particolare perché oggi qui con me c'è
un amico che probabilmente conoscete
tutti possono conoscere
forse non ti conosce nessuno sai
[Musica]
mi conosci non ha scherzato lo so chi
sei però ero piccolo quando andava in
onda su bim bum bam
se tu sei one io sono qui perché siccome
so che i giovani ormai guardano le
internet
voglio diventare famosa su su che cosa è
diventata realtà
nel sito www non è niente c'è e le
chiese di un'associazione voluta ma
successivo era internet si scrive in
italiano
su internet è un'altra cosa l'avrebbe
come si diventa famosi ci sono tante
cose che ti prende in considerazione
prima cosa devi tenere conto dei due
persone che ti seguono dei followers che
li segue tanti saluti se no non ti
seguono in questo senso li guardano
quello che fai persone mi spiano quindi
devi prima cosa che devi fare è aprire
un canale non ho guardato dalla coop
e poi non so neanche nuotare ci sono
delle cose che devi fare per presentati
a tipo ci sono dei dei blog che puoi
farti da non sceglierà queste cose in
televisione 12 troppe parolacce
[Musica]
funziona come devo inventare un nome
d'arte e chi può
monici parigi può funzionare però magari
forse non è un po troppo simile a
qualcuno ma perché fabi per che fare e
chiede sono fai più intenso fasti di una
volta ma si fa massi di nuovo magari
perché io ho deciso di fare questo video
ci sono altre no secondo te chi guarda
il rosa va molto per il fashion blogger
in questo caso di pesci no passion
fashion blogger mi confondo per le
persone che fanno video sul trucco e
cose del genere
però non so se i tuoi video che chiedo
bella io ho pensato mio credo che di
battaglia la conseguirlo che tipo bella
ma con la one one ho capito solo sun
capito ho capito ho capito ma credo che
così ti farai odiare più che amare dal
pubblico
io andavo in onda tutti i giorni per due
ore ora i media di due ore funzionano
no il video di dolore adesso sono la
morte
se vuoi fare video di nuoro e vai a fare
video con piero angela non confavi j con
favino di 10.000 si chiama pt rosica
macchina si chiama non mi fare queste
domande così un'altra cosa
importantissima risentirla quanto fai la
pubblicità si allora si chiama non si
chiama pubblicità ma si chiamano place
ma lo faccio tutti i giorni
poi ha trasmesso io lo studio il
presente certo che per essere perfetta
napoli deve passare modello è il verbo
guardino placement significa in italiano
si va piazzamento vuol dire che metti
qualcosa nel video e lo promuovono
piazzo qui davanti si piazzi qualcosa
guido assai promuovi ti volevo piazzare
le cose che ciò che lo sai che devi
alzare un prodotto per farlo vedere
io sono sei ma ciò la pena quaderno per
gli appunti tegolino secoli dai tutta la
scatola del classico topolino mulino
bianco
ok va bene io ho quello al cacao che
tegolino ora facciamo così fammi vedere
come faresti un placement sul canale vai
bravo e buono il classico tegolino
mulino bianco con questi geni si osa
pardi spagna
io amo la spagna ho sempre amato la
spagna si fermino che la strada quanto
più calmo per un posto tranquillo pacato
per ogni volta non un pacato in questo
senso il pacato nel senso che visto il
più sciolto devi vivere tela di più e
siamo arrivati faccio vedere io come si
fa a me mi viene innanzitutto è ripetuto
troppe volte la parola tipo ad esempio
mulino bianco e che la gente lo sa carte
golino e del vino bianco e poi non lo
fai in modo naturale se non devi dire
tipo tegolino al cacao ma il momento in
cui chi fa maschi e chiedo mi seguì a
giocare commentando vuoi giocare
commentando dalla vuoi fare il grande
passo
ci siamo da qui i verdi facciamo al
grande passo da fermi si va bene ti
spiego come si fanno il gameplay questi
commenti
per fare un video gameplay deve
innanzitutto utilizzare il joystick
quindi questo qui però devi utilizzare
nel modo giusto taschino che stai così
così perfetto di bene una volta che ha
il joystick devi avere anche lo
strumento del mestiere
sto parlando di questo è quanto di
meglio è per sentire molto bene perfetto
ma sta anche bene sassa signor mike a io
sono pronto qual è la domanda no non si
da mai che non s'era mai ascoli anno
10mila non è un video quiz vedi lo
schermo giochiamo di guardarli bene
bene se la cavi anche abbastanza
justin è tardi manovella anche quando
non è che poi c'è i commenti cosa devo
fare di rispondere oppure face superiore
che dico che ciò d'affari che sono
troppi i pignoramenti devi rispondere
perché noi youtuber abbiamo il contatto
diretto con chi ci sei mi devi
rispondere anche perché i fan ti danno
dei consigli e quindi di crearti un
profilo ma io sono addirittura due
questo è agibile e questo mi piace di
più no non ci voglio creare cosa fra
deve saper fare ma io dico pero l'unica
cosa che deve saper fare l'orecchio per
l'unica sarà saper intrattenere il
proprio pubblico
si sa che cose complicate che fate voi
certo che deve aver studiato parecchio
si trovi il segno vecchio diano un video
allora a chiudere il vino one è la cosa
più semplice che esista deve ringraziare
i suoi fan per averti seguito fino
adesso quindi grazie ragazzi facciamo il
suo sogno e giuliano cosimo video ciao
ciao ciao
senti io poi chiudere vorrei fare un
senso così momento si sta garantiva se
facciamo se è che un self un self in un
autoscatto prodi sorridere ci sei
[Musica]